today I'll be presenting about big data
big brain data science and produce
health analytics so to begin with I want
to show you a brief outline of what I
would be covering in the next 40 to 45
minutes today first of all I'll start
off with discussing some driving
biomedical and health challenges that
lead to some of the necessary
developments in the data science world
in a computational statistics world so
then I would focus on identifying some
of the common characteristics that
oftentimes describe big brain data I
will explicitly define what I mean by
data science and predictive analytics
and I will go over several case studies
specifically in the domain of
neurodegenerative disorders I'll show
you one a cool application of data
dashboard in using the soccer dashboard
web app and I finally he'll present to
you the idea behind a really interest in
new methodological developments
something called compressive big data
analytics that is intended to provide a
canonical way of mathematically
representing statistically analyzing and
computationally processing large complex
heterogeneous data sets so that's the
outline so let's start off with some of
some examples of driving biomedical and
health challenges so this is a recent
study that we did a year and a half two
years ago looking at how most diseases
specifically as a component of the new
vast spectrum of neurodegenerative
disorders so in that specific study we
had about 800 hours a most diseased
subjects coming from the outside of
disease neuroimaging initiative a large
public-private initiative to aggregate
very heterogeneous multi-source
multi-institutional collection of data
for patients commerce disease patients
as well as asymptomatic controls and
these individuals that are kind of
transitioning from being controls into
being patients something called MCI soar
mildly cognitively impaired individuals
so in this specific study we looked at
the three different cohorts and what we
did is we extracted about eighty what we
call derive neural imaging biomarkers
and then additional 80 associated snips
that were highly associated with the
with the diagnosis in this case controls
MC eyes and 80s in that kind of
progressive spectrum so the images on
the left here kind of illustrate some of
the parcel ations that we did for the
brain and some of the statistics that we
extract and you can find more about that
study in that publication so there is a
you know the recognition that when you
do when you analyze biomedical or health
data there is typically three facets of
variability that one needs to be aware
of the first the first one is obviously
the phenotype which is the outward
manifestation of the form shape size
characterization of the specific
individual if you're doing precision
medicine on individual level or cohort
based science atlas based studies and
population-based studies or you can be
doing a phenotyping based on various
comorbid conditions in addition to the
phenotype we have obviously the nature
or the genome that plays role in
everything that we look at in biomedical
world and then there is also the nurture
and the environment now across these
three pillars I guess of natural studies
chance plays a big role so there is
random effects there is noise that needs
to be deal with and one of the the on
the right side here I try to indicate
this notion that most of the studies
effectively resolve into trying to tease
out effective biological signal relative
to the natural
presence of biological noise as well as
noise that's technically introduced by
the equipment by humans by the
processing etc so most of the studies
that people do effectively revolve
around trying to maximize the
information content or the signal
relative to the corresponding noise that
is unavoidable to a large extent so in
this next slide I'm trying to make the
case for why should we look at big data
and what is big data and what is
standard data or clásico or small data
so in this left panel here I have a
representation of a natural process here
so the native process could be you know
something that inscribing in this
specific case go blue here with with
different type of characteristics for
these individuals colors orientations of
these subjects and so forth and then on
the extreme on there on the right hand
side you have typical what a sample data
set represents you know it's a it's a
snapshot that's there is pretending to
be a proxy of the actual population
which oftentimes is not completely
observable through a census so most of
time we review these limited process
snapshots of the observations and we try
to make the inference using data on the
bottom right corner to infer the
scripture that's on the bottom left
corner now big data is this kind of
in-between case where you're collecting
obviously not a census of the population
but you're collecting sufficient amount
of large-scale information about the
process looking at different directions
different scale different modalities etc
and you're trying to again do the same
thing you're trying to infer
characterization of computable
phenotypes on the actual native process
which is oftentimes not observable in
its entirety so obviously there's pros
and cons for looking at sample based
inference statistics versus looking at
big data inference where you know
there's lots of challenges in terms of
the harmonization the aggregation the
processing etc
so by the way my colleague Krystal she's
gonna be reviewing if anybody has any
questions you can post them in the chat
and towards the end we'll probably have
a chance to go over some questions or
comments that may arise during the
presentation so in this next slide I'm
showing you the what we call the
constructive definition of big
biomedical data so big data obviously
was first defined by IBM in terms of the
four V's about a decade ago they
recognized that the volume the variety
the speed at which data changes and the
veracity are important characteristics
and they call these four V's now these
four V's are nowadays extended to 70s
and 80s there is more of the words that
describe the complexities that have to
do with big data
now last year what we did is we try to
come up with a more structured
constructive definition that identifies
very specifically what are the
challenges and what are their needs for
tools software and services there are
very specific to these what we call big
biomedical data big brain data etc so
the size is obviously one of these
characteristics it's one of the
Paramount characteristics but we don't
stop there there is complexities to the
data that requires special type of data
handlers Wranglers that allow us to
manipulate heterogeneous data elements
then you have data in congruence the
data would not become a homologous
between subjects between sites that are
acquiring the data and so forth so
sampling rates so there's a lot of tools
that are necessary and techniques to
deal with this in congruence another
very important characteristics of big
data is that it oftentimes arrives from
multiple sources so the transfer the
joint modeling and processing of these
disparate elements is a huge barrier
currently then you can be looking at the
same process the same phenomenon for
example the human brain at multiple
scales starting on the top at the
macroscopic level you have typically
resolution of the brain at about one
and then you can go down to cryo
tomographic data where you you can have
you know microscopic or meso scale and
if you can go down to the nano scale or
single channel recordings where you're
on the micron level so you're looking at
the exactly the same substrate exactly
the same process but you're looking at
different resolution so the multi scale
aspect of big-brained data is very
important and last but certainly not
least is the fact that big data is
always always incomplete so mechanisms
of dealing with that incompleteness you
know our group and other groups are
developing batch mode techniques because
oftentimes if you have as soon as you
cross the ten to a hundred thousand
cases you can do it you cannot it's
simply computationally impractical with
current technology to do holistic what's
called imputation to obtain complete
snapshots of the data that can be
processed using more traditional
techniques so let's go ahead and define
specifically what we mean by data
science and predictive analytics because
these terms are important so in my world
data science is defined as this emerging
extremely transdisciplinary area which
bridges the theoretical the
computational the experimental and then
the biosocial or the biomedical areas
data science deals with with these
characteristics that I defined earlier
these enormous amounts of complex
incongruent heterogeneous dynamically
changing data that arrives from multiple
streams or multiple sources data science
always develops methods tests methods
validates methods shares methods to
services and capabilities to enable
ingestion of these complex datasets and
applying completely automated or
semi-automated decision support methods
and systems predictive analytics is the
process that we use for utilizing
advanced mathematical formalization
powerful statistical algorithms and
efficient software to
Jews as well as Web Services to number
one represent number two interrogate a
number three interpret complex data sets
so predictive analytics focuses on
identifying trends clusters motifs
progressed prognostication of processed
behaviors either across time space
within range in outside of the range of
the originally observed data and again I
want to remind you of the little cartoon
that I had early on about the complete
population data of the GoBlue a
schematic versus the big data set and
the small samples of traditional samples
because this notion of observing data
outside of range and inside of the range
is very important so and by the way
these two definitions come up from there
directly coming from an upcoming
Springer book on the topic of data
science and predictive analytics so this
is a diagram that illustrates a typical
process when you are analyzing big brain
data the typical process starts with
collecting the data that comes as raw
observations bits bytes that are
typically aggregated you have data
scrubbing data cleaning manipulations
and so forth that need to be conducted
first before some kind of an information
gets extracted out of these data for
instance summary statistics in our case
we take the raw imaging magnetic
resonance imaging scans for example and
then we remove the non series knowns non
brain tissue then we model the cortical
surface of the brain which is the
boundary between the gray matter and the
cerebrospinal fluid using mathematical
two dimensional manifolds so that's in
the information content and then the
next step the next column here is the
knowledge generation phase at which you
begin to look at these models and you
obtained summary statistics so for
example you can be computing surface
areas you can be computing shaping this
is you can be computing fractal
dimension you can be computing a variety
of morphometry measures for each of
these areas
and then based on these you typically
develop learning algorithms or
classifiers that can lead to some action
that obviously in in our world pertains
to mediating normal development or
variance heterogeneous brain disorders
so I want to start with some examples
now now our case study so in the first
case this is a case that we have
amyotrophic lateral sclerosis a very
debilitating progressive
neurodegenerative disorders so we wanted
to identify predictive mechanisms to
detect track and prognosticate the
progression of a OS across time now
although a OS is not extremely common
there is about 30 to 50,000 cases in the
u.s. it is very debilitating it's also
called in Lou Gehrig's disease and
Stephen Hawking is one of those
prominent outspoken obviously patients
with ALS so in this specific case we had
a very heterogeneous data set that
started again over a hundred different
features were recorded for a number of
subjects they include a demographic data
clinical data what are called AOS fr-s
these amyotrophic lateral sclerosis
functional rating scale clinical
measures there were in addition adverse
events included with some of the
patients and we started with about
eighty six hundred cases and in the
process of you know stratifying the data
and manipulating the data to the point
where it becomes a single computable
object that can be jointly modeled and
interrogated the data was reduced to
about 2,400 cases simply you know to
avoid missing us to avoid incongruencies
and so forth and then we we looked in
despair in this specific case trying to
predict the progression of the disease
in terms of monitoring these AOS fr-s
lat
Trix very specifically finding the slope
so we are given the information at
baseline zero month and then at month
three you know one one quarter later
we're given this information we're asked
to predict a 12-month follow-up where is
the AOS FRS clinical score for these
patients going to be so we developed
this fairly elaborate protocol that's
shown in the left that kind of
illustrates very concretely how we go
from the original observations all the
way down to the predictions and then the
assessment of these predictions in terms
of various quantitative evaluation
metrics the panel on the Left kind of
shows you the variable importance plot
that kind of directly identifies
features that are important in that
prediction of the 12-month follow-up
from the first three months of
observations and then the table on the
bottom right kind of illustrates three
different types of classifiers ma linear
model based techniques and then three
model freak machine learning based
techniques using random forests based on
adaptive regression trees and a super
learning method and then the rows in
this table kind of illustrate three very
specific metrics that quantify the
performance one is called the r-square
metric that identifies the relative
model performance the root mean square
error and then the correlation between
the actual observed AOS FRS slope change
between the first three months and the
12-month and the actual predicted by the
corresponding method slope change and
you can see that we are reaching about
0.5 or so prediction accuracy the second
neurodegenerative study that I want to
point out is a Parkinson's disease study
so there is something very similar for
Parkinson's as there is for AOS there is
a clinical scores called uniform
Parkinson's disease rating scale
assessments and again we are
are trying to predict the progression of
the clinical diagnosis of the of the
patients can we separate
for instance patients from each match
controls with and without using the
corresponding UPD RS clinical
assessments that the physicians base
their diagnosis on so the table on the
bottom kind of illustrates again a
little bit about the cohort you know
there is genetics data there is imaging
data there is three different cohorts
asymptomatic controls or their controls
the patient of the PD patients and then
there is these patients that are in
between their coats Weds subjects
without evidence of dopaminergic deficit
so if you look at their imaging scans
the radiologist cannot clearly identify
a Parkinson's disease deficit in terms
of dopamine change so for that specific
study we again developed an end-to-end
protocol that starts with the data
aggregation on the very left it goes
through the data harmonization
aggregation of all these different
modalities of the data coming from the
multiple sources there vary in congruent
they cannot be represented in the same
functional basis then we did a clean in
the imputation they the wrangling of the
data and then because the cohorts in the
previous slide it was shown that the
sizes of the three different cohorts
that we are studying are not very
balanced so for example the patient's
outnumbered controls three to one
there's a potential bias that may be
introduced by the by the patient cohort
so we used a synthetic minority over
sampling method which is statistical
technique that allow us to rebalance
approximately not exactly but
approximately the sample size of the
three cohorts so that we avoid potential
bias and then we did both just like in
the arrow s world we did both model
based for example linear Mauro and model
free classification of all the patients
and then we did predictions and we
validated the results the
workflow diagram that's in the bottom
left corner here shows you the
end-to-end protocol the data goes
essentially over 80 to 90 different
processing steps to go from its raw
aggregated state into some of these
cortical surface maps and parcel it maps
and statistical signature vectors is
what we call these numbers that drive
the actual classification at the end and
on the right hand side you have again of
their importance plot that kind of
illustrates which feature and you can
see here there is demographic features
like age there's imaging features like
the left superior occipital gyrus
surface here is one of these features
you have clinical measures the PDS part
one was highly predictive of the
diagnostic outcome of the subjects etc
and you can see in the bottom right
table again some stunning statistics and
these are certainly not surprising you
know
adaptive boosting and support vector
machine classifiers were able to
discriminate between the different
diagnostic cohorts incredibly well now
this was simply because we use the
actual you PDR as the uniform
Parkinson's disease rating scale
measures which the physicians themselves
used in the determination of a diagnosis
when we exclude these clinical you PDRs
biomarkers our classification goes down
to about eighty percent which is a
substantial decrease however it is still
pretty impactful and reliable indication
that machine learning methods can be
used to do fairly powerful predictive
analytics so in this specific case three
just to summarize we have developed an
end-to-end big brain data analytical
protocol that can join the model
represent and interrogate image in
genetic clinical and demographic data to
assess the risk for Parkinson's disease
the source code is available on github
site under the predictive big data
analytics soccer sub project
now let me follow up with something very
recent so this is hot off the presses
they say although it's not yet
peer-reviewed it is a very very
interesting new study looking at
Parkinson's disease patient Falls can
you predict a physical injury from
falling in Parkinson's disease so in
Parkinson's disease there is two
clinical phenotypes there is tremor
dominance with people that have limbs
that basically shake and the second type
is called gait instability and postural
instability or portion instability in
game disorder so these are freezing of
gait and various other disorders so in
this specific case we were interested in
doing three very specific challenges the
first one is we had data from two
different sources here at the University
of Michigan we have a you know Center
for Excellence in Parkinson's disease a
you 50-grand funded by the National
Institutes of Health where we are
collecting a lot of data on Parkinson's
patients and a colleague of ours at Tel
Aviv University collected completely
independently a very similar data set
against are in the same cohort not the
same individuals the same cohort of PD
subjects so the first challenge in this
study was to try to harmonize and
aggregate this multi source and complex
data set the second challenge was to
identify what are the clinically
relevant features that are associated
with very specific clinical traits for
example Falls okay and the third one is
trying to predict now once you have the
feature selection can you predict Falls
in these Parkinson's disease using again
model based or model free machine
learning methods so this the study
design is illustrated in this diagram
first of all we did this independently
study the Utah University of Michigan
data set within the feature selection we
did a modeling with its what's called
statistical internal cross-validation of
the results and we did this
independently for the two data sets that
Tel Aviv University data set and you
know
then in the second phase we actually are
aggregated the two dataset and then we
did the modeling and the
cross-validation on the aggregate data
set as well as we did we did an external
out-of-bag training on one of the data
sets and testing or assessment on the
other so the results were fairly
encouraging we have as I mentioned you
know a missing data is one of these key
challenges that characterizes big
biomedical data and Big Brain data in
specific so this diagram only the the
chart on the left corner here shows you
the missing pattern of the data and then
on the right on the top right I canna
show you some of the differences in
various in for clinical clinically
relevant variables like tremor score
posture into the instability engage the
solar score and in various other metrics
between the followers and the non
followers indicated with purple and
yellow colors and then one of the big
challenges that occurred in this case
study which is certainly very common
when you do a big biomedical data is the
fact that the data will not be congruent
or statistically aggregate able so the
diagram that you see the histogram plot
on the bottom left corner illustrates
the very substantial amount of
difference between the distributions of
various features between the Michigan
and the Tel Aviv data so everything that
exceeds that threshold that red curve
that I hope is visible here the
horizontal red curve this is inverse a
log scale of the statistical
significance on a coma Gaurav Smirnoff
test between different features and you
can see about half the features are not
statistically distinct between the two
populations but a huge number of
features are very very distinct between
the two University databases so how can
this be explained how then how can this
be handled to allow us to literally
aggregate and learn from up from a
bigger dataset so okay so so we we move
forward we we we dealt with these
challenges and I just want to show you
some of the results so we did the
feature selection by two different very
interesting methods one is called a
random forest feature selection and you
can see in the middle column here they
defeat the feature name the variable
names and then right next to it the
frequency of how frequent he land and
how common was it how important was it
in the prediction of the clinically
relevant outcome in this case falling or
nor falling and then knock off filtering
the second column in this table on the
right illustrates a controlled variable
selection where you you have a mechanism
of controlling the false positive rate
of selecting these features and you can
see that seven of these features are
commonly chosen by the two completely
independent strategies so that's a very
strong indicator that we might have zero
down on which observations which data
elements would be highly predictive or
associated with Falls in Parkinson's the
bottom right table that's shown here in
the corner illustrates a variety of
metrics from model-based logistic
regression of identifying follow some
known followers to random forests
adaptive boosting FG boosting a number
of alternative machine learning based
methods and you can see that you know
one of the best classifier in this case
random forests achieves you know
accuracy of about 80 percent with fairly
high specificity of about points 87 and
you know sensitivity not as good but
about 0.7 so this is again fairly
encouraging now once you have that you
can obviously make recommendations to
physicians families caregivers and so
forth about what to watch for or what to
look at now in this next case study we
looked at a more generic population you
know almost looking at the census so
this data comes from the United Kingdom
this is the UK biobank in this specific
case that we wanted to discriminate
between here
the patients and multiple comorbid with
multiple comorbid conditions now in the
UK biobank data what is interesting is
that they try to take a snapshot of the
of the entire population in this case
and this kind of shows a little bit
about the data so over half a million
cases over 4,000 features they do
include imaging data not for all the
subjects but for many subjects about
10,000 subjects they have structural and
functional imaging and diffusion imaging
data they have genetics data and so
forth so it was a very challenging study
and the URL links that are provided here
in the bottom right corner might be
useful if you want to follow up for this
this is all public data you can request
data so just to show you some of the
complexities here right so we looked at
the features these you know literally
4,100 features and we only looked at the
ones that are highly observed so more
than 30 percent of the cases having
observed data and this is just a plot to
illustrate the the misenus rate okay so
it turns out that in our situation we
essentially want to do zero down on the
subjects that had imaging data because
we know really well how to do
computational neuroscience we know how
to obtain these derived neuroimaging
signature vectors so for these 10,000
subjects as you can see you know ninety
nine hundred or so cases we looked at
the highly observed clinical phenotypes
about these 1500 or so features and we
wanted to examine what is the missing
pattern what features are missing what
is the rate of missing and as you can
see here there is a very high rate of
missingness so we needed to develop
techniques to deal with that misenus the
missing misses off is not random as you
can see from that pattern so innovative
statistical methods are are required to
be able to pre-process this specific
data set to the point where it can
become again a computable data object
that we can interrogate either with or
without model-based techniques so little
about the protocol so we developed this
pipeline workflow that kind of shows on
a very high level here the process is
that the imaging data goes through from
volume pre-processing to parcel ation to
computational the morphometry measures
all the way up to the result aggregation
into these spreadsheets or computable
data objects so not everything on when
you do computing on this kind of scale
not everything is gonna be perfect
you're gonna have some successes and
some failures so I'm just showing you
here that when you do a computer in this
scale things are not always gonna be a
right so in this specific case we have
99% of the it says eighty thousand three
hundred and forty eight compute jobs
were done at the specific phase of the
pipeline workflow 99% of them are
complete one was canceled and 469
instances of the calculations failed so
we can track down it is very important
through the Loney pipeline environment
to be able to track precisely what steps
and what cases fail so that you can
remedy and examine if there is anything
common for them now obviously your
inference needs to be based on the
complete cases kind of going forward a
little bit about the pipeline a workflow
environment that we've been developing
it at low nyan and the ini at USC this
has been a project that again has
started as being funded as a p41 project
part of the National Institutes of
Health it allows users to design on
their client machine these complicated
protocols so that the calculations can
be outsourced to an external pipeline
distributed server where the
calculations can be parallelized on
complex computational platforms so the
user doesn't have to worry about
managing of the data node assignment job
tracking aggregation of results and so
forth this is all kind of managed by the
distributed pipeline server on the
the user only worries about the
front-end design of the actual
scientific protocol the algorithm the
pipeline workflow that's what we do and
then our colleagues at IT and and the
pipeline team actually worry about all
the back end things that are indeed very
important for these types of
calculations so this is a slide that
shows you a tool that we developed as
part of the Big Data discovery science
bd2k Center a couple years ago it's
called the Big Data dashboard it allows
you to essentially query databases
multivariate multi-source databases
without writing a single line of SQL or
any database language code you
essentially visually generate a collage
of images each image representing one or
multiple variables and then all of these
are charts are interactive so there are
like trellis charts you can narrow the
scope of the state so for example you
can select states where you can select
in this case this is the histogram of
the average commute time for these
individuals so you can manipulate any
one of these charts and as you
manipulate one of them all the other
charts morph to reflect the the subset
in there to reflect the stratification
that the user introduces in one or
several of these charts so during that
interactive visual based data
interrogation you are able to formulate
interest in research hypotheses about
what might be the multivariate intricate
relations that are not a priori known so
we can generate hypotheses that can
obviously be tested to rigorous
computational mechanisms so in this
example that I just show you we we used
data from the Center for Medicare
Services the CMS under Medicare services
we used data from the US Census Bureau
and the Bureau of Labor Statistics just
to illustrate how data can be pulled
from multiple incongruent in this case
federal
databases but they're not designed to
necessarily interoperate so we
demonstrate how the data can be
aggregated and therefore interrogated
real-time through visual analytic
concepts alright so in the last few
minutes I just want to tell you about
this compressive big data analytics a
strategy that our group is developing so
a little bit of motivation here there is
no current mathematical foundation of
how to analyze big data the science the
big data science is not developed so we
have looked at again the big data
characteristics and we have introduced
this strategy that allows us to do a
stochastic based inference independent
of the very specific case based data
characteristics as long as the data has
these six dimensions that I showed in
one of my earlier slides large-sized
coming from a multiple sources
incongruence Multi multi scale
incomplete and so forth we are
developing this iterative statistical
stochastic algorithm that would allow us
to generically process the data in such
a way that we generate sub samples on
the Big Data then we use model based on
model free techniques to analyze these
samples compute various likelihood
estimates relations or quantity
qualitative or quantitative relations
between variables we repeat this process
multiple times and we effectively look
at the asymptotics we look at the
organic properties of these algorithms
so this diagram kind of illustrates a
little bit of process it's a a step
process very very generic it's not it
doesn't deal with brain data it doesn't
deal with neural degenerative data it
deals with any data set that has the six
dimensions that I outlined earlier about
big biomedical data set so the first
step
is obviously the pre-processing Clinic's
cleans that you know eliminating very
strong dependencies brick casting
datatype were necessary dealing with
machinist and so forth in step two it
does the data harmonization right the
data set just like in d you now Michigan
versus Tel Aviv Parkinson disease false
data said that I'll show you there has
to be a data aggregation and
harmonization step in in data in the
second step we do the select the
variable selection and so forth and then
we go through the iterating big cbda the
compressive big data analytics iterative
protocol where we randomly sample in
step four a decent set then we do the
imputation scaling rebalancing which I
mentioned earlier as well when we did
the Parkinson's disease study then we do
the knockoff controlled variable
selection or perhaps other variable
selection it doesn't have to be knockoff
and we apply multiple machine learning
methods like the super learner then we
go ahead and rank mean square root
errors or accuracy metrics to identify
how consistent are our results across
different iterations and then we in the
final step we do the feature mining that
allows us to identify these variables
that are highly that appear frequently
across the multiple random walks through
the cloud of data so it is a very
interesting algorithm we are right now
in the process of validating it so more
on that later but I want to point out
some very important things for us as a
community to look at the fair data and
open science principles ofer refers to
findable a refers to accessible the I
refers to interoperable and our refers
to reusable data set so as we all
collect manage process and understand a
complex data set we we should always
keep these four in mind and I'm sure
many of us do this is very important and
the open science aspects again not only
for the publications but my group the
soccer group is actually using open
continuous development you know all of
these things that I'm showing to you the
CBD a method it's Orion github even
before it's being published sharing the
data or the data the code and the
science is being shared at the time of
development it's not shared after post
hoc it is shared during the process of
development so this obviously entices
new investigators to contribute share
collaborate extend and so forth so final
this final example I know we're
approaching 1250 here on the East Coast
and 950 on the west coast here in the US
so the last thing that I just want to
show is it is another very interesting
data set now in this case about 60,000
patients and we looked at hospital
admissions the data is not very
feature-rich in this case only nine
features are recorded including
admission the length of the admission a
binary indicator variable of whether the
patient survived etc and some
demographics we used very similar
predictors trying to identify for
instance can we figure out who at the
time of admission is likely to die right
so this confusion matrix that you have
in the in the bottom right here on the
bottom left corner kind of illustrates
that the survivals are ninety nine
hundred you know it identifies the
patients that we the algorithm in this
case random forest classify this patient
that are expected to die versus how many
did die so we have this confusion matrix
and you can see that we have a fairly
decent
internal cross-validation accuracy of
about eighty five percent the
sensitivity is very high about 93% of
specificity however is low only 13%
which indicates that we have a very very
low rate of falsely
identifying individual as expected died
when they survived but we we might have
a fairly large rate of false negative
identification so people that did die we
might have missed them on the bottom
right corner we use this algorithm to on
a completely independent data set of
11,000 to 12,000 subjects to essentially
predict the probability of survival you
know what is that probability we're not
interested in binary classifying
individuals as surviving we just want to
have a likelihood which would help
physicians clinicians and the caregivers
we in addition so this is completely
automated decision support system that
adds up another level of quantitative
description about likelihood of survival
or not so just to give you a again
coming back to the National Health
Service in the UK you know we have begun
the very same exploratory data analytics
using machine learning methods on on all
of their data we have developing these
workflows we're looking at their
genotypes and ultimately where we're
trying to design these connector grams
that that shows us on the left on the
left hemisphere here you have some brain
regions or clinical phenotypes on the
right hemisphere you had some of these
genomic biomarkers for instance so
finally in the interest of time I'm
going to skip this very interesting
traumatic brain injury study because I
do want to leave a few moments for
questions and you know the secret source
of success are three things right you
have to have the funding agencies you
have to have the collaborators and and
you have to have the infrastructure to
do that type of study so right up here
you have again recognition of the
funding agencies as well as the
corresponding grant IDs students fellows
coworkers are very important in this
research big brain data and predictive
Calton
is a very transdisciplinary area no one
can do this individually or even as in
one lab you have to have colleagues from
multiple disciplines from multiple
institutions to do this kind of research
and of course you have to have the
infrastructure because without the
computing resources without the storage
without the expertise much of this
research is going to be very difficult
so thank you very much I'll be more than
happy to address questions now thank you
so much Eva that was an outstanding tour
of all these big data analytic projects
that you've had going on one of the
things which strikes me before but
before I ask my question I want to
invite members of our audience if you
have any questions please use the little
GoToWebinar question submission system
which is in that panel that's probably
on the right side of your screen to type
in your question and we'll get those
texted in and then we can ask those of
dr. D knob Evo how important is quality
control or some level of quality
assurance of these variety of data sets
that you're pulling from I in particular
I was struck with all the different
publicly available governmental
databases that you're pulling from do
you go through any quality assessment
level assessment of that data to go in
and make sure that it's you know valid
and and make some sense and how do you
look for outliers and that sort of thing
yeah that's a very good question and a
very common question Jackie and I will
tell you for the dashboard example that
is rated with the CMS Bureau of Labor
Statistics and the Census Bureau we did
go through a very manual labor intensive
quality control for instance just to
give you an example there were millions
of records and the federal government
databases are for mistakes about three
to five percent of the data was wrong we
were able to correct about two to three
percent of them simply by cross
validating for example things like FIPS
codes and zip codes and lo cow and
whatnot so there is mechanisms that you
can do well I don't know
semi-intelligent quality control so
that's on one level right so there
mechanisms and and you can do this on a
larger scale however this process is not
practical and there is a danger there is
a danger that if you collect a big data
set it could represent a very
substantially biased or non
representative data that's always going
to be the case now the hope is that as
we collectively as community improve the
data quality there will be mistakes but
these mistakes on average over the
distribution of the data they're going
to be representative of the population
so my personal approach is that we try
to do quality control the best we can as
long as it doesn't overwhelm us
initially and secondarily we are hoping
and we are to some extent validating
whether or not the data is
representative of the census and that's
that's a difficult challenge without a
doubt hmm
so we have a question from one of our
audience and and I was particularly
interested to is you were going to
discuss how you use predictive analytics
in traumatic brain injury patients and I
was hoping to see a little more
description of that before you skip
through it and it looks like somebody
else from our audience was - can you
take a second to just kind of summarize
that for us
right absolutely so let me talk over
this a little bit and there we a video I
hope that a place right so so the
traumatic brain injury is incredibly
interesting and incredibly challenging
the basic challenge is the heterogeneity
of the morbid condition right everybody
can imagine that every single traumatic
brain injury is different so in this
video here we kind of illustrate in how
we collected data from multiple sources
from multiple individuals we have access
to the infrastructure the pipeline
computing server that you see and the
pipeline graphical workflow environment
and now what we try to do is we
literally individually process every
single subject so we postulated the
brain
we looked at the morphometry metrics
that we can automatically compute for
every region for every subject we're
able to reconstruct their cortical
surfaces and not only that you know
oftentimes the injury the injuries is
very important right is the injury the
gray matter is defecting the myelinated
white matter tracks how severe is it you
know quantifying some of these things as
well as the visual representation are
very important and TBI needs to be done
on an individual case oh so look what's
happening with this specific is this
image is gonna shift now a little bit
you can see that the injury of this
patient was in the inferior temporal
lobe can you everybody see the huge gap
that we have in the cavity that's
indicative of exactly where the injuries
how large is it how complex is it so
these things are very important and then
we try to look in this specific case we
trying to see if P if the type of injury
was it a gunshot a motor vehicle or
bicycle accident and unfortunate we only
have about 40 to 50 cases in this case
we were trying to identify a specific
commonalities we did not have enough
power to identify anything critical but
the process that we went through was
very powerful because we haven't built
the protocol we know how to analyze
these cases we just need additional
obviously data and a more processing
power to be able to obtain these on a
larger scale because without hundreds to
thousands of cases the heterogeneity of
TBI is is really limiting the scope of
any method model based on model free to
yield anything substantially interesting
that's interesting you know we have a
question from one of our audience asking
about it in the big data era this era of
gathering evermore larger datasets one
of the first things people seem to be
interested in doing is applying machine
learning techniques in order to
be able to make predictions about
classifying subjects or being able to
make predictions about you know what
something might be or or or whatnot
whether but the alternative is can we
make inferences and how do we make
inferences even though we can make these
algorithms which do prediction and is
there a distinction and how can we
identify features or the relative
importance of some variables versus
others and you're uniquely qualified to
comment on this so I thought I'd throw
this back to you right so so so that's a
very interesting point I want to start
off by saying that data science is
recognized effectively by many of us as
the fourth scientific pillar in addition
to the experimental sciences that
started during you know well during the
Renaissance era to the theoretical
science Sciences that started you know
in the 1780 in the nineteenth century
the computational science sciences which
effectively matured in the 20th century
in the 21st century we have the data
sciences and it is true that you can
scientific discovery can be hypothesis
driven or exploratory so this can be
called exploratory versus confirmatory
science machine learning methods can be
used for both you can use machine
learning methods to formulate a research
testable hypotheses that can be
prospectively tested or validated using
other methods but it can be used for
inference as well simply because still
the statisticians in the past decade
have realized very interesting
phenomenon okay hypothesis based
inference is back is rooted in the
notion that you quantify uncertainty in
terms of p-values data science inference
is rooted in the understanding that the
probability values that you compute here
are replaced by or or augmented by
looking at quality metrics like the log
odds range
like the positive or negative predictive
power like the sensitivity and
specificity on a statistical
cross-validation world so in other words
we pull the data where every element can
be used or every case can be used both
as an element that we learn from and as
an element that we can assess the
predictive power of these algorithms so
it is very interesting it's very rapidly
evolving field obviously there'll be
mistakes let me remind you of the Google
Flu Trends fluke you know things are not
going to some things are not going to
well work well some things will work
well and I know I'm out of time so I'll
stop here but any other questions or or
quick ideas Jack I think we've run out
of time but I do hope that our audience
will feel free to find dr. dena at the
University of Michigan and and shoot him
an email should you have any additional
questions for him I'm sure that he'd be
delighted to answer them but I hope
you'll also join me in thanking dr. Dino
for his presentation on big data brain
science print predictive health
analytics for our bd2k guide to the
fundamentals of data science thank you
so much Evo is absolute pleasure and I
want to thank our audience for taking
the time and today to join us I want to
wish everybody a Happy Holidays and do
watch for this will be our last data
science seminar for 2017 but start
watching for a new collection of these
to begin shortly after the new year once
again thank you everybody happy holidays
and my best to you and yours for the
remainder of the year anyway thanks so
much again it was a pleasure thank you
jack